guess what i fixed the toilet last night
most of the time when stuff like that
happens i'm like oh help me
oh god like but last night i was like
you know what
just lifted the lid off rolled up the
sleeves
went in yanked the chain reattached it
and it worked
yes that's right everybody i climbed a
domestic everest and
after the show i was thinking i want to
empower other women to do the same thing
and not feel like a damsel in distress
are you wondering why i'm wearing this
when i say that
i don't want to be a damsel in distress
so when i heard about judealynn cassidy
a plumber and activist for women working
in the trade business
i had to meet her and she created a
non-profit called tools
and tiaras maybe making sense now that's
right
she teaches young women everything from
plumbing to electrical work
and even auto mechanics and she's
today's wildflower
and she's here with us now
[Applause]
thank you for having me oh i love you so
much i'm so happy you're here i have
been so
excited about this segment me too
because i did
i finally did something for myself
instead of calling for help
and it was really empowering and it made
me realize that i'm at the tip of the
iceberg
and then jessica yank lunas put us
together and i've been
like waiting to do this with you
likewise and
let me ask you a question why did you
decide to
get into the business that you're in
plumbing i decided to get into this
business
honestly drew yeah for the money dude
i love it so that's the first reason and
then i
love being a plumber i love that answer
it's so refreshing because i want to
carve out a path for myself
that will be financially viable that's
an
excellent reason and what did you want
to teach
other girls as you empowered yourself
with a financially viable job
and something that makes you feel like
you can do anything yeah the reason for
doing that i wanted every little girl
growing up to know that she can be a
laborer or a welder an iron worker
even a president so i wanted girls to
believe
and truly embrace the idea that jobs
don't
have genders and you trademark that yes
and you should because it's funny
that a sentence like that seems so
logical
and yet when i heard it i was like oh my
god you gotta say that because
it's so eye-opening at the same time yes
it is just imagine i'm really tiny as
you can see
four foot eleven and seven eighths and i
do this
and you are a true bad i don't think
christmas yeah anyway let me
say it but you know what i'm thinking um
okay well
will you teach me because i was like
okay tip of the iceberg i want to go to
the next step i want to learn learn
learn
can you teach me what the next thing to
tackle is
yes well you did the first one which
we're going to do today and a lot of
people at home you all have toilet boats
that are running and mother earth
she is crying because she's a source not
a resource
so in order to do that
and that's my friend teo always tells me
that and the next step you're going to
do you're going to go to your bathroom
and you're going to face your toilet
on the left-hand side of your toilet
bowl when you face it
right you're going to shut off the water
supply
you have to shut off the water so we can
save water there's something down there
yes a shuttle valve drew you you've seen
it i mean i've definitely been in this
position
and i never saw that before it's there
but i was probably wearing a tiara come
to think of it
actually all right so the next step drew
after we
shut the water off everyone at home
don't forget
shut the water all right we're going to
take the tank cover off
place it to the side right and now
you're going to flush the toilet to
remove
the contents that are in the tank yeah
yeah this is like a perfect toilet this
is
what it normally looks like yeah at home
you're gonna have it looking totally
different
just flush it empty it you're gonna get
you're gonna locate where the flapper is
and you're going to disconnect it from
the chain
yeah the chain from the handle all right
connecting it
nice you pull it right yeah put some
little gold power in there and pull it
off
the old one oh my god
drew you fine on the new chain you have
uh a chain on there the new flapper you
have a chain ah
good oh very good oh dear what have i
done all right it's off it's okay this
looks like an
organ no so
the next drill you're going to take your
rag yeah i don't hide it yeah it's right
there it's on the front it is
there and then you're going to take it
and wipe where you just took the flapper
off
okay at home you will have debris so you
want to wipe it
put that aside get the new flapper
right and you're going to clip it you
see the hook right there everyone
you're going to take that and hook it
back yeah exactly where you're supposed
to hook it it's not making sense
i totally get it and now you're going to
reattach the chain
onto the handle uh-huh you got this yeah
oh yeah i do
all right good
next you're going to take the tank cover
cover it back and don't forget you did
shut the water off
so we got to turn it back on that's
right let's go back down drew get back
in the position yes you're gonna go uh
lefty loosey
and loosen it and righty tighty right
yeah
okay and then you're gonna turn the
water back on
and now we flush success
you guys and motherless mother earth is
saying thank you drew
could i learn more from you because i
know you're teaching all these amazing
girls in fact you can go to our website
at drewberrymore.com
and look at judelyn's amazing program
tools and tiaras
will you come back and teach us more oh
yeah i want
to be more like you and wait like this
if you want to be more like me drew
and be part of the hashtag girl gang
hashtag again
i got you oh thank you here put it down
and then i'll come grab it you know
christine is watching right but it's
okay here we go sprite
thank you oh my god you this is the
coolest thing ever
thank you now you could start to put
tools in there and become one of the
awesome trades women
group that i belong to by the way i'm
not kidding
changes everything guess what i'm gonna
look like on saturday
thank you
[Music]